[Music]  you got this yummy in the rain you get  rules I'd say you got nothing life  history with all these cheap shots  people like me living past you got  people that need you now you got  everything go loose this guy has got  nothing in loose mind got a choice  that's to say that your father said and  he died right here in my hands he said  me this guy is dangerous but you don't  think I can beat I was afraid I couldn't  live up to these expectations  you don't think you got your validation  I want to be right history don't pretend  this is about your father  [Music]  and may not seem like you now but this  is more than just fight  is that my DNA  [Music]  [Applause]